protesters who overran key political
landmarks on saturday say they are
staying till the president and prime
minister resign
thousands of others are streaming in to
visit the official residences
and this property the presidential
secretariat we need a new system we need
a new governance we need new we need
proper leaders so today we are to change
that and to bring this nation our
country to a stable position we are
until we are fighting until the end
that end seems close but protesters are
not leaving
they are angry and fed up with having to
spend days in queues and to find the
money to buy essentials which have
increased three to five times in price
president gotab rajapaksa says he will
resign on wednesday
political parties in parliament will
elect a new president a week later
a government has to function according
to the law i'm here to protect the
constitution and through it fulfill the
people's demands what we need today is
an all-party government and we will take
steps to establish that
getting agreement among different
parties won't be easy and there are
warnings that it shouldn't take too long
the central bank governor has said that
uh there has to be political stability
very quickly in order to have the
international community the
international monetary fund with whom
negotiations are taking place in order
to ensure that that support comes in
anger against the president and his
government have been building for months
the lack of fuel has had a major impact
on people's lives
on monday a few fuel stations received
new supplies
for five days we have to wait for the
queue but they are giving thousand five
hundred rupees for the bikes that means
three liters really does not enough for
us we are working in the courier service
that is only for one days it is enough
as negotiations continue about a
peaceful transition of power people are
hoping this brings them some relief
miner fernandez al jazeera colombo